raus aus der toilette mit reise in die
straße die pride paraden stehen seit gut
40 jahren für das schrille coming out
auf der ganzen welt seit 1938 steht
homosexualität in der schweiz nicht mehr
unter strafe
in zürich entwickelte sich ab den 50er
jahren eine lebhafte schwulenszene am
theater neumarkt fanden damals legendäre
bälle statt zu denen schwule aus ganz
polen reisen
jetzt ruft an film dieser elfer in
erinnerung
petra schimanski geglaubten mehr
schaffen
süßes
die liebesgeschichte die sich im film
zwischen einem lehrer und einem
travestiekünstler entspinnt ist in der
realität ihre geschichte ihr ab und erst
seit sie sich an jedem ball kennenlernen
um sind sie ein paar
seit 58 jahren für sie waren die 50er
jahre eine glückliche zeit im alltag war
verstecken zwar oberstes gebot im
neumarkt aber lockte das leben als fest-
und die einzige zieht noch mal ganz
natürlich und freier könne sie ich sind
ihr hobby das sie im kreis das netzwerk
hatte sich der kreis man fühlte sich als
kreis von gleichgesinnten ab 1943
verschickte die organisation eine 2
später dreisprachige zeitschrift in alle
welt für bis zu 2000 abonnenten
erotisch aber nicht allzu erotische
durfte sie seien die sittenpolizei übte
zensur fotografie akte in frontalansicht
verboten züchtig mit lendenschurz den
hintern oder von der seite erlaubt man
passt sich an wollte skandale vermeiden
und dann oben drauf ich sein
foto volante immer nach aktbilder voll
aktbilder slö stimmt uns befriedigt
hatte sich am ende im bilderdienst und
hat dann jedem heft be quite die mine
verfügt über hochmoderne folgt auf
norbert rink ende der 50er jahre drehte
da bitte loggen sie sich bitte geworden
auslöser waren morde im strich am nil
die polizei begann sogenannte homo
register anzulegen razzien durchzuführen
und die schwulen zu erpressen
mit 3 4 das tabu das grusical berät das
ich brauche ja mitten und reis diese
schöne braver gute schweiz sei nicht
seriös kommen dann die polizei wohnt
sind die ihr die barren und über als
gestern
da das tool sich trafen die ganzen tag
hinter dem lager aus öffentlich also oft
öffentlich hinter den bau gestellt und
habe alles ausgelotet und 0.30 uhr die
stadt zürich verfügte ein tanzverbot für
schule und er zog damit dem kreis die
finanzielle grundlage 1967 löste sich
das netzwerk auf
die zeit der demütigungen der ängste und
des versteckspiels ist vorbei ernst
osterwalder sind mit ihrer geschichte
längst versöhnt
2003 waren sie die ersten die sich in
zürich das jawort gab